j'ai attention décembre 99 avec un
téléphone portable et une escouette de
mutin le général gay arrache le pouvoir
aux hritier corrompu de l'ancien
président au fou BO il libère des
opposants et s'engage à rendre le
pouvoir une fois passé je cite un bon
coup de
B mais 10 mois plus tard en troquant le
TR pour le costume de candidat à la
présidence celui que les Ivoiriens avait
surnommé le général Père Noël s'est
transformé en père
fouard il fait invalider la candidature
de ces Rivau politiques a une exception
prês et sa milice liquide dans l'ombre
plusieurs de ses anciens frères d'armes
en septembre il échappera de justesse à
la vindicte d'une armée qu'il ne
contrôle plus depuis
longtemps on essayant hier de convaincre
manu militari le président de la
commission électorale de le déclarer
président élu le général gay joue le
coup de force et perd ses derniers
soutiens
internationaux en février celui qui
voulait faire marcher la démocratie
ivoirienne au pasquencé avait aussi
tenté de mettre au pas les joueurs de la
sélection nationale ivoirienne éliminé
en Coupe
d'Afrique il y a quelques jours le
général gay disait sans rire désunis
nous courons à l'échec unis nous y
parviendrons c'est bien involontairement
la seule promesse qu'il est vraiment
tenue